Miyoko Shinner is a Japanese immigrant...
...who has been a vegan for four decades.
She has been making vegan cheese and butter...
...since getting her start, teaching cooking classes...
...and hosting a cooking show.
After promoting her fourth cookbook,...
...which featured cheese made from cashews,...
...she started Miyoko's Creamery in 2014.
The brand now sells alternatives...
...to butter, cream cheese and mozzarella at 20,000 stores...
...including Walmart and Target.
So when I started it, I thought it was really just sort of a stab in the dark.
Was it going to have any traction at all?
Was anyone even going to buy the product?
And I was just shocked when I found that the demand was so strong...
...and then we just started growing at 100% year over year.
Shinner now employs some 170 workers and has raised more than 20 million dollars.